so we've been discussing the seven years
war in north america also commonly
called the french and indian war but as
i mentioned in the last video i think
seven years war is a better name for
this conflict because it was the first
global war that happened more than 150
years before world war one and this
global war was at its heart about who
would be the dominant empire in the
world would it be england or would it be
france
now in the north american theater of
this war
england france and their native american
allies on both sides were vying for
territory and particularly territory
along the appalachian mountain range in
upstate new york
canada this kind of western territory
that was the border between the english
settlement and indian country to the
west
so in this video let's talk about how
the war actually progressed and what its
consequences were for north america and
later the united states
all right so we've got the english the
french and
a number of native american tribes all
kind of jostling for position in north
america now what stresses the british
out the most is
the presence of the french in the ohio
river valley both the british and the
french have laid claim to this territory
and they're both eager to strengthen
their territorial claims
by building forts
and otherwise having a show of
possession of the area
they argue over who had a presence there
first
so to establish the english presence in
the ohio river valley the english send a
young officer named george washington
to build a fort george washington is
only
22 years old at the time
and he and his men go out
to this area and they run into some
french with their native american allies
at fort duquesne which is where the
allegheny monongahela and ohio rivers
come together which is today pittsburgh
so george washington and his allies get
the jump on the french but that doesn't
last very long they're overpowered and
they fall back and establish
fort necessity
on account of it was necessary
and they managed to hold out for a
little while but eventually the french
the canadians and their native american
allies
force washington to surrender and he
goes back to virginia so that's 1754.
and we'll call that fail number one
all right so then a year later
1755 the british try to displace the
french from fort duquesne once again and
they send major general edward braddock
with
george washington once again now he's 23
back to fort duquesne and
it's a complete disaster this time the
french and their indian allies get the
drop on the english and with a much
smaller force completely decimate the
english troops
braddock is killed
and george washington has to take
command
of the retreat so that's fail number two
in general this war does not go terribly
well for the british at the beginning
except in one area acadia where the
british manage to attain control and
they kick out the french settlers
the acadians who are transported
down to the french settlement of new
orleans
in louisiana
where eventually their name becomes
garbled and they're known as the cajuns
not the acadians but the cajuns
in 1756
england finally gets around to actually
declaring war on france
but it's really not for another year
that the war starts to actually go well
in 1757
and the reason that the war starts going
well for the english finally is that the
prime minister william pitt
decides that he is going to
pour
money into this endeavor
so he thinks that the english have just
not had enough men materials money
indian allies up until this point so he
is really going to
commit the british empire
to
exiling the french from this area of
north america
so between 1757 and 1760
things really start looking up for the
british
they finally capture
fort duquesne
and
they capture the ohio valley
nova scotia
upstate new york
and quebec
so by 1760
pretty much all the fighting is done in
north america the english have more or
less forced the french
out of the eastern seaboard and canada
and in 1763 the english and the french
sit down to hammer out the treaty of
paris
so the treaty of paris in 1763
and i apologize i cannot help the fact
that there are like a million treaties
of paris there's also the treaty of
paris that ended the revolutionary war
there's the treaty of paris that ended
the spanish-american war paris was the
place where you made treaties and
they're all called the treaty of paris
but this is the one that happened in
1763.
in general this was a big victory
for the english
the english
not only got
most of france's possessions in the new
world they got
new france aka canada
they got
spanish florida
uh spain was fighting on the side of
france so they lose that they got a
bunch of sugar islands
in the caribbean
and they
pretty much got recognized as the
premier power in europe
and the premier imperial power
so
the largest and most powerful
empire in the world
and let's not forget that the colonial
americans
citizens of massachusetts and new york
pennsylvania virginia they were on the
winning side here
they fought alongside the british
regulars
they
repelled the french and their native
american allies this was actually a
pretty big confidence boost
for
young america
but there were some other consequences
of this war
on the not so good side the seven years
war was not particularly good for
native americans in general
both those who had allied with the
british
and those who had allied with the french
they no longer had two
imperial powers
vying against each other in north
america that they could play off of each
other now native americans were only
dealing with the british
who certainly we're not giving them a
fair seat at the table
not long after the seven years war they
will institute what's called the
proclamation
of 1763
which was
basically a boundary line
along the appalachian mountains
saying that that was going to be the end
of white settlement that they would
reserve
all the lands west of the appalachians
for native americans well you can
imagine how much the american white
settlers respected that which is to say
they completely ignored this boundary
line so the native americans will
continue to be
pushed farther west
and to develop more of what we call a
race consciousness
the idea that they were all in one big
group together who had to combine forces
to repel english settlement the other
major outcome of the seven years war was
taxation
remember that william pitt won the seven
years war by pouring money into it at
the end of the seven years war
england is in a lot of debt
and they have just gone to a lot of
trouble
to
protect their north american interests
now as they are looking for
ways to make revenue to make up the
deficit the seven years war has placed
on them they look at their north
american colonists and say you should
pay your way
and
the american colonists who have been
used to more than a century of called
salutary or benign neglect
are shocked and outraged that the
british empire is now clamping down on
them and the colonists reaction to those
new taxes will propel the colonies into
revolution